i am gagged every day that
you know my authenticity
has become the reason
for my success
i'm a testament to
choosing your authenticity choosing
yourself it's really
it's really powerful and i am grateful i
hate when people say i'm brave you're
transitioning so young i don't tell you
how brave you are it's not that brave if
you're just being who you are i have to
say
that it found me
this piece found me and it found me
because of the choices and decisions
i've made in my life you know over 20
years ago i chose myself i chose my
authenticity at a time when that was not
popular it's easy to be who you are and
what you are is what's popular but i
chose myself anyway
and as a result
[Music]
you know my queerness
that i was told would be my liability
and it was for decades
has become my superpower we could live
our own life or spend the rest of our
life wondering
what if it's a gift it's a blessing it's
humbling
to know that i stand at the intersection
of filling this void
and holding the world accountable that's
what we get to do with our art that's
what we get to do as artists
we get to transform you know reach into
the hearts and minds of people and
change the molecular structure from the
inside out
that's what we're here for i'm so proud
of this film i'm so proud of the you
know my my babies in this film
you know our screenwriter himana you
know it's a new voice
i'm very proud for the first time in my
life i'm actually excited about what's
to come i truly feel anything's possible